Let's start with looking at
an example of an AI agent in action.
Many are you are family with Watson,
the IBM program that plays Jeopardy.
Some of you may not be, and that's fine,
we'll show an example in a minute.
When you watch Watson in action,
try to think.
What are some of the things
Watson must know about?
What are some of the things that Watson
must be able to reason about in order
to play Jeopardy?
Write them down.
And anytime you feel the pain,
hey, this guy refrain.
Don't carry the world
upon your shoulders.
Watson?
>> Who is, Jude?
>> Yes.
>> Olympic Oddities, for 200.
>> Milorad Cavic almost upset
this man's perfect 2008 Olympics,
losing to him by
one-hundredth of a second.
Watson.
>> Who is Michael Phelps.
>> Yes, go.
>> Name the decade for 200.
>> Disneyland opens and
the peace symbol is create.
>> Ken.
>> What are the 50s?
>> Yes.
>> Final Frontiers for 1,000, Alex.
>> Tickets aren't needed for this event,
a black hole's boundary from
which matter can not escape.
Watson.
>> What is event horizon?